[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga DWS
international talk show coming to you
from Berlin
I'm Brian Thomas great to have you with
us when the counting was over it was
spin time in Washington with both
Republicans and Democrats saying they
were the victors as they plot the course
towards the presidential election in two
years so who won the midterms jubilant
Democrats celebrating their new control
of the house with full powers now to
subpoena investigate and hold up
legislation for the Republicans
deepening their Senate victory gives
them a powerful tool as well and for
Donald Trump well the loss of the house
means he'll have to find a whole new way
of being America's president us midterms
tough times for Trump that's our topic
today and to discuss it I'm happy to be
joined by Griff witty he's the bureau
chief of the Washington Post in Berlin
he says both sides can claim victory and
both have real reason to worry
Matthew carton shake is cheap Europe
correspondent for Politico he says Trump
can still galvanize large portions of
the American electorate a fact that will
worry many people both inside and
outside the US with just two years until
the next presidential election and rikka
habits works as an editor for the weekly
eat site she says the midterms showed
the force of female power and the
results limit Donald Trump's power to
some extent but the country will remain
deeply divided a warm welcome to all of
you great to have you here Rikka if I
can start with you you're talking about
the role of women in this election have
women in America completely redesigned
the political landscape in this election
oh well I wouldn't go as far as say they
redesigned the whole political landscape
but we have seen that never in history
have been more women in Parliament than
right now I mean they've been I think
combined represented house of
representatives and sentence is more
than a hundred and what we have seen is
that women are mobilizing I mean there
are more women that are like gaining
power and I think
is something that was very optimistic
about the election day and I think that
is something very optimistic for the
Democratic Party I think they should
gain that momentum and try to speak more
to women who leaning towards voting for
Democrats and I think that is the key
for 2020 having go people go vote and I
think the women is a key electorate and
the Democrats showed yesterday that they
can appeal to those groups especially
suburban women and urban women were key
in this vote Matthew were they pivotal
do you think or were there other groups
as well I think they're absolutely
pivotal especially in these former
Republican suburbs that you know appear
to have gone in the Democratic direction
and their women played a very important
roles under the suburban mom that you
know tends to be conservative but really
isn't happy with the way Trump comports
himself with the way that you know he's
addressing a lot of the issues of the
day and and you know I think they're off
by Trump's personal style turned off by
his personal style his rhetoric you know
obviously the the the some of the issues
involving women the the Cavanagh
nomination the Supreme Court nomination
that really galvanized a lot of women I
think to actually go and vote and that
clearly played a role here in many
people's minds so I think it was a
factor it'll continue to be a factor
although at the end of the day you know
a lot of these races went down similarly
to the way the 2016 presidential
election went between Trump and Hillary
Clinton of course hey Grif if you were
going to give the Trump administration
some advice to win back these key
suburban and urban female voters what
would you tell them well far be it from
me to give Trump advice I don't think he
would take advice from a Washington Post
reporter but I think that you know
obviously Trump has to make a decision
he can continue to govern in the style
that he has which is to be deliberately
provocative polarizing to intentionally
alienate a lot of people but also win
some real diehard fans oh or he can try
to reach out and be a more bipartisan
figure someone who is less abrasive
someone who is less interested in
attacking and more interested in going
for some kind of consensus I don't know
that it's in Donald Trump's DNA
to do the latter I think this is a
politician who knows one way of
governing one way of doing politics and
it's to be abrasive to attack and it's
he saw in his comments yesterday he
thinks he had a great night on Tuesday
he thinks that he won and so I don't
think there's anything in the results
that's necessarily going to change his
behavior but he's right isn't he for the
candidates that he barnstormed for most
of them did in fact when so there was an
element of success in how he approached
campaigning for the midterms this was an
election that didn't go as badly as it
could have gone for Donald Trump I think
there were a lot of liberals and
Democrats in America who comforted
themselves after 2016 and said he was
just a fluke 2016 was a one-time event
never going to happen again what we saw
with the results on Tuesday was that
there is a real polarization in America
it continues and he has a real base of
support there he does have to worry
though
because you saw in 2016 he blew a hole
in the blue in the blue wall this this
famous blue wall he got states like
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania the
Upper Midwest states industrial states
he won back those Rust Belt voters and
you saw on Tuesday night that that
Democrats did very well in those states
they won congressional seats they won
governorships and so I think he has to
be very concerned he can't just the
Republicans won Florida they won some
other big states but if they lose
Wisconsin Pennsylvania and Michigan it's
all over for them in 2020 it will be
wounded Errico when you look at what
happened would you call a winner in
these elections was it the Democrats was
it the Republicans I think it's really
really hard to pick a winner here it's
muddled isn't it it is it's kind of a
mixed bag I mean for the Democrats it
was clearly a good night because they
won back the majority in the House of
Representatives they showed that they
get their voters out which is so crucial
in midterm elections but then again the
the Republicans they even got more seats
in the Senate so they only had a slight
majority in the Senate now they have a
bigger majority there so I think I see
the point in Trump saying well this was
a good night for us because the blue
wave that everybody hoped for who was
born left-wing it wasn't really a big
wave it was not crushing the Republican
Party but then we then when if we look
at Texas I mean the Republicans want
Texas but how close
was that a mainstreaming close it was
impossible to think that Texas would
even remotely go to like a Democratic
candidate and was so close and I think
that is where the Democratic Party can
draw hope from that they're winning back
Rust Belt states that they get close
races in states that have been red for
almost centuries and so I think it's a
really mixed bag but I think the
Democratic Party should gain that
momentum and should be smart about that
but the question is will the Democratic
Party be smart about it okay are they
Matthew what do you think will they
regroup looking at what happened what do
you see the Democrats doing moving
forward well I think we're gonna see
more of the same they're gonna continue
to pour money I think into these areas
where they think they have a chance our
home state of Arizona for example these
states that appear to be shifting a
little bit from the conservative camp
towards the Democrats some people call
them purple states and you're seeing a
very interesting phenomenon in these
places where the urban areas are clearly
moving towards the Democrats and in many
cases are already pretty solidly blue
whereas the rural areas remain red
remain Republican and I think this is
going to be the challenge in two years
because it doesn't matter how many votes
you get at the end of the day in a lot
of places it matters you know what you
get in the electoral college and so this
means that the rural areas in the
electoral college is very important
that's important for language not to
lose sight of that right and and and
it's more reflective of the United
States sent Senate which Trump held here
than it is of the House of
Representatives and I think this is this
is a very important point a crucial
point going forward because as you said
those areas where Trump really made a
strong effort to campaign for people he
won and these were races in many cases
where the Democrats had very high hopes
in Florida in Georgia the governor's
race in Texas as you mentioned and in
Arizona and some of those races aren't
haven't been called yet they're too
close to call but it looks like they're
moving towards the Republicans the rural
urban divide was emphasized by the vote
that we saw in the midterms it's almost
like there's two different Americas
there's there were two issues the
Democrats campaigning and voting for
health care for example and and the
Republicans and Donald Trump backing
them with of course
migration are we seeing two Americas
clashing in electoral cycles oh yes I
believe totally that that is true and
that Donald Trump is the president who
who wants that and he wants to widen
this division and he is not a president
who says we need to unite I think he
wants this polarization I think the
American Society has been as polarized
as it can be there is not one single
issue gun's women's rights religion
health care where you have to pick a
side I mean there's hardly any
compromise from the outside it looks
like there's no compromise there's no
common ground for compromise it's
either/or and the political parties both
play that game and I think that is
deeply troubling because they the the
politics should try to work together to
compromise to reunite a society that has
been clearly divided on a lot of issues
okay one of those big issues is abortion
there was a referendum in Iowa that
passed them that considers life when the
first heartbeat of a fetus can be heard
now this is going to clear the path for
a Supreme Court challenge on abortion is
that something these midterms brought
into focus as well a broad panoply of
different issues not just migration not
just healthcare but a one that's often
overlooked abortion for example well
this has been kind of you know the
central issue for many of trumps
supporters you know since the roe versus
wade Supreme Court decision in the early
70s which legalized abortion and this is
the long game that they're playing they
want to put judges onto the Supreme
Court who were going to which they now
have the power to do and as you say
people forgotten about this issue it's
something that's been at the center of
the political agenda for a lot of
evangelical Christians for example for
quite a long time and so I wouldn't be
surprised if this issue you know keeps
coming up and it is something it is a
very powerful reason for many people who
wouldn't otherwise support Trump to vote
for him because they say yes you know
I'm an evangelical Christian I don't
like a lot of what he's doing but I know
that he's going to choose
the kind of judges who were going to
overturn the abortion - Sophie wait and
be straight-up
right for life so they're locked down
the evangelical Christians now a poll in
the spring published on the Axios news
website showed a full 60 percent of
respondents wanted legal not illegal
immigration levels cut now the issue was
brought to a head by the so called
Caravan heading north to the US border
during these midterms the president made
it as we've been talking about the
centerpiece of his midterm brains
barnstorming Donald Trump describes the
migrant caravan as a threat to the
United States he says criminals and
terrorists are mixed in with a 6,000
migrants and the refugees are carrying
diseases we have people coming into the
country of trying to come in we're
stopping a lot of them but we're taking
people out of the country you wouldn't
believe how bad these people these are
people these are animals Trump's own
principal campaign promises to get tough
on asylum seekers
he plans to send up to 15,000 US troops
to stop them as many as a currently
stationed in Afghanistan and they have
orders to shoot now Trump saying he
wants to abolish the law guaranteeing US
citizenship to children born in the
United States of foreign parents
children are made automatic citizens of
the United States every year because of
this crazy lunatic policy that we can
end nationalism and scaremongering once
again Trump's going for the gut with his
populist rhetoric but do his politics of
fear work
was the president fear-mongering on
migration oh yes absolutely I mean it's
kind of sad to see how these people that
are on track to come to the United
States they they kind of he
instrumentalized them and it was just
for him it was just such a lucky thing
to happen just straight before the
midterms I mean it's heartbreaking for
these people but for him it was of
course great because he could like play
his migration card he can I mean he said
he won't like change the birthright
citizenship thing I mean that is part of
the amendment of the Constitution he
cannot just do that but of course he
stands there and says I'm doing it
anyways and I go to the Supreme Court to
do it and of course I mean that is what
is deeply troubling with everything he
wants to do he doesn't have the majority
in the house right now but he still has
the power over who becomes a judge and I
mean we've seen that there were two
Supreme Court seats vacant while he was
president both were nominated with him
from from him with conservative judges
and that's like a decision for life I
think that is what is troubling me a lot
politics can change but what re I mean
the courts don't because that's like a
position for life and he will play that
card over and over again and of course
people are afraid and he just like
pushes people to be even more afraid and
I think that is a very horrible thing to
do but was that griffa a strategic error
should the president of contra
concentrated more on some of his
economic successes I think a lot of
House Republicans would say yes if you
got them caught them in a moment of
honesty behind closed doors I think that
they wanted the the Republicans to run
on their record which actually when you
look at the economy is a very good one
you have one of the lowest unemployment
rates in recent American history you
have real wage growth this is an economy
that's that's going on all cylinders and
I think there were a lot of Republicans
in these swing districts who would have
liked a more unified less controversial
less polarizing message of hey we're
creating jobs we're putting money in
your pockets Trump doesn't do that kind
of politics though he does the
polarization he does the inflammatory
and so he focused on immigration and I
think it is a real question for a lot of
Republicans who
lost in these swing districts if the
message had been one of we've
accomplished a lot economically and had
not been this deliberately abrasive
style of politics
what would they still be members of
Congress today okay um
Matthew the Republicans would say well
the Democrats do their own
fear-mongering we're gonna take away
your health care we're gonna make cuts
to Social Security is there a
qualitative difference between how the
Democrats address some issues and how
Donald Trump does yeah I think there is
I think that Trump you know it takes
things you know up another level from
what has been kind of you know the
traditional partisan politics if you
will and you know certainly his
references to the the caravan and so
forth reflect that I don't think that
there's any other politician mainstream
politician in recent American history
either on the left or the right
who would resort to those to that kind
of a rhetoric and that's why you know he
is part entertainer he's part politician
and this is the attraction of a lot of
people for a lot of people to him I
think also on the Left he's somebody
that people love to hate and he sort of
captivated you know the United States
and and the world and everybody sort of
tuning in to see what crazy thing he
does next and I think the question after
this election though is you know how
sustainable is it I don't know that his
attacks on the migrants for example that
that really works I I think you know
we're gonna have to wait and see what
what the data says about that how many
people really responded to that because
he's sort of you know going back to the
old themes that you know helped win him
the presidency but if those are issues
that really resonate still isn't clear
to me because you know as you said rika
the the Democrats did make inroads in
these former Republican stronghold so
that's got to worry the Republicans a
little bit I mean overall I think that
the you know the shift of the house to
the Democrats can't be that surprising
that is if you if you stand back that's
the historic norm you know usually that
is residents come in with both houses of
Congress in their pocket they tend to
lose you know the the house at the
midterm but you know there are have been
presidents who despite losing that end
up winning a second term that happened
you know Bill Clinton won a second term
Barack Obama won a second term and they
both
at the midterm election just like like
like Trump has so I wouldn't say this is
necessarily too negative for Trump at
the end of the day I think the jury's
still out okay what could be negative
for him though is the firing of Jeff
Sessions now he's made a tactical
decision here to protect himself and
attack basically the Moller
investigation the Russia probe was that
a wise decision and will the Democrats
Griff pick up on that and subpoena
investigate and make life difficult at
that level now after this firing for
Donald Trump I think absolutely I think
you know Washington is a very different
place now than it was before the
election before the election was
effectively a one-party town Republicans
controlled if the White House and they
controlled both houses of Congress the
Democrats now have the house and that
makes a big difference that's they they
have subpoena power they control those
committees they can basically drive the
White House crazy just sending subpoena
after subpoena after subpoena and Trump
is betting that he can fire Jeff
Sessions and that there won't be much of
a repercussion for that maybe the the
replacement as Attorney General will try
to shut down the Moller investigation
which he's he said as a television
analyst that that is what the
administration should do but I think
that you're gonna see a real really
strong pushback from the house side on
that the question I think is do any
Republicans also stand up and say that's
what what Trump is doing is wrong and
what if they try to shut down that
investigation that's obstruction of
justice or do do Republicans stay stick
with Trump and stay in lockstep with
with him I think that there's a real
potential ultimately for a
constitutional crisis here and I think
that that's one of the big big questions
to watch over the coming months
Arica there's been a lot of concerns
expressed in the German press about
America's system of checks and balances
isn't working we're facing Chuck Schumer
the Democratic leader was saying a
possible constitutional crisis when you
look at the midterms and the Democrats
recapturing the house are you reassured
that the American system works well kind
of because everything you said I think
is true I mean the Democrats will try to
to
use the regained power in the House of
Representatives and I think it's so
important for the American political
system to have checks and balances in
place I mean that's imminent for the
system so I'm happy to have seen that
yesterday that they regained the power
but then again I mean it's like it's not
oh not only a day after he fires Jeff
Sessions and the new Congress only comes
into session in January so there's eight
weeks to go and we don't know what will
happen and everybody always says well
Trump cannot fire mother and he hasn't
done so yet but I mean every time we say
Trump cannot do this or that he does it
I mean it's so unpredictable and there
is still eight weeks where the old
Congress is still in session so I'm just
hoping we make it to January and then
the Democratic Party can play its role
and then we will see checks and balance
be in place again okay so you're you
feel confident that we will see checks
and balances I am exerting there do
functions Matthew when you look at the
house of victory with the Democrats the
way you cover European politics and
German politics do you think something
that's something the German populace and
German politicians are profoundly
welcoming right now absolutely I think
that any check on Trump's power is
something that that Europeans of all
stripes of all political stripes would
welcome because they see him as a loose
cannon they see him as dangerous see you
miss somebody who opposes you know their
core values and that is undermining the
transatlantic relationship which has
been key obviously to European security
since the Second World War so I think
anything that dilutes Donald Trump's
power is something that people here will
will look at very positively but I have
you know I think in in you know people
also need to be careful what what what
they wish for because as he comes under
pressure I think he will become more
unpredictable in the sessions thing is
the first indication of that and the
risk here is that he does end up firing
Muller or ending the Moller
investigation and this turns into a very
a partisan issue that he tries to paint
the entire Russia investigation which he
already is doing and has done as a
witch-hunt but say it's a democratic
witch-hunt and now they're you know
they're they're sitting all of these
people and try to discredit it that way
and you know that could happen that
could happen very very quickly and it
certainly seems that's the direction
that we're heading since we've uh
mentioned Russia Grif I'd like to ask
you when when you consider America's
adversaries we've been talking about
America's friends right now Germany and
Europe
when you look at Russia for example in
China do you think they could feel
emboldened by a weakened president now
that the Republicans have lost the house
and feel emboldened to foreign
adventures of South China Seas Ukraine
are too hot potential flash points right
now I think they felt emboldened for a
while now I think that they see an
America that is in general weakened on
the on the world stage and now you have
such deep fractures within the Western
alliance and the fact that Trump and
Europe are at odds with each other the
fact that Trump is is portraying Europe
as in in some cases an adversary of the
United States which i think is is you
know a complete shock to European
leaders for Russia and China that's
that's a godsend they're there so they
see this as a moment that they can
capitalize on they're trying to
capitalize on it they are capitalizing
on it and I think that that that will
continue and it would if would have
continued regardless of who would won
the election on Tuesday okay what do you
think Matthew is this is this a cause
for concern for America about emboldened
enemies or is America going through a
necessary process right now of dealing
with an increased level of diversity on
so many different levels and redefining
itself it's a process of national
redefinition well I do think it's a
natural evolution i I think that the
both the Chinese and the Russians
realized though that Trump's power in
terms of the executive office that he
holds and and his decision-making power
over the military and so forth that
hasn't been diluted he still has the
final say on a lot of these crucial
issues so if they were to try to do
something in the South China Sea or in
Ukraine I mean that that's that dynamic
is not going to change and I think they
realized that
but overall I think that this is very
good news for America's enemies you know
they they like anything that is really
disruptive and certainly the Russians
this is always you know the their their
ultimate goal is to destabilize the
political system as much as possible and
you know we're heading into a situation
now with the Russia investigation that
could be quite chaotic so it's
definitely good for people who want to
dilute America's power in the world
what's your main takeaway from this
midterm election recount slightly
optimistic but I fear that we have to
live with from a little while longer and
that it's getting more chaotic
I believe that as well and that the
polarization will not stop anytime soon
Grif I think both parties are going to
have to do some hard thinking after this
election and for Democrats especially
they now the race for 2020 starts it
started on Wednesday it's already
underway and there aren't really clear
lessons from this election but they're
gonna have to figure out which direction
they want to go in I'd like to thank all
my guests for being with us today for
all their comments and input I'd like to
thank you as well for being with with
quadriga don't forget to join us next
week until then i'm brian thomas
goodbye til that
[Music]
you